Обвинувачений ховає обличчя від телекамер.
Так завершився один з найгучніших російсько-європейських
пропагандистських скандалів останнього часу.
Крапку у "справі дівчинки Лізи" поставив суд берлінського району Тірґартен.
Слідство з"ясувало -
біженці не викрадали і не ґвалтували неповнолітню Лізу
з родини переселенців з колишнього Радянського Союзу,
як заявляли у січні минулого року російські ЗМІ.
Але в результаті скандалу поліція вийшла на 24-річного Іcмета -
уродженця Берліна турецького походження.
13-річна Ліза зустрічалася з ним за півроку до скандалу
- і саме за зв"язок з неповнолітньою
громадянин Німеччини Ісмет отримав вирок.
Обвинуваченого в тяжкому сексуальному насильстві над неповнолітньою
та виготовленні порнографії засудили до одного року
і дев"яти місяців позбавлення волі умовно.
Обвинувачений визнав свою провину,
тому суду не довелось вислуховувати свідчення потерпілої.
Через дражливий характер справи пресу пустили тільки на перші хвилини засідання.
Через 2 години суд виніс вирок.
Хоча початок скандалу навколо "дівчинки Лізи", на противагу фіналу,
був гучним та дуже емоційним.
Він спалахнув, коли родичі Лізи дали інтерв"ю російським телеканалам про те,
що дівчинку викрала і зґвалтувала група біженців.
Це викликало хвилю обурення в соціальних медіа,
поліцію звинуватили в потуранні злочинцям.
Міністр закордонних справ Росії Сергій Лавров закликав Берлін до відповіді,
а в Німеччині відбулися акції протесту російських німців.
Тільки згодом з"ясувалося,
що насправді ніякого викрадення не було.
Дівчинка все вигадала,
бо не хотіла розповідати батькам про проблеми в школі.
Зараз багато російських німців
воліють не згадувати про те,
як вони повірили чуткам,
що їх поширювала російська пропаганда.
А для німецької влади скандал з дівчинокю Лізою
став тривожним дзвіночком.
Він показав,
як за допомогою лише однієї фейкової історії
можна вплинули на громадську думку.